ryan starts off this hour in akron ohio
hey ryan how are you
i'm doing well how are you dave better
than i deserve what's up in your world
awesome hey well i've always enjoyed
personal financing learning about it
and in college i'd even help friends you
know make budgets it's just basic stuff
like that and i just got so excited
about it
i know i wanted to help people with
their money um and i graduated this past
may may 2020
got a job at a bank because i thought
you know that's a great place to help
people with their money
and that's right around this time i
started to listen to your show
consistently
and really do the baby steps for myself
good for you
how many you yeah yeah i've seen how
many uh
lives your plan has changed dramatically
and i feel like um the stories i hear on
your show
are from people who would walk into the
bank
and i would feel pressure you know for
my boss and from corporate to
sell credit cards and sell home equity
lines of credit
i feel like i'm in this position where
i'm putting people
uh in a position to you know
come to your show like you know what i
mean like
um i just feel like i'm pushing i you
know my job is to push
debt and more debt and i'm just
wondering where
you know in the financial world can i go
um where this isn't the you know
tool of making money for companies is
debt
yeah well i mean if you work in a pizza
place you're gonna be selling pizza
that's the way it works so i mean that's
um
and if you're health food nut that
probably is not going to be right
not going to be congruent right yeah so
that that's kind of where you find
yourself
um a lot of people with your itch
gravitate towards the uh
the investment advisory side of the
business like our smart vester pros
where you work for a a local
organization that is a member of a
broker dealer and you help people
get investments going and most of those
people do not pedal debt
most of them peddle investments uh and
they some of them
go extend beyond that into some
basic financial planning like they'll
hook you up to help you get a will or
they'll hook you up in that world they
do now
our smart mr pros generally just do
investing but
the ones that we endorse but uh um you
know some of them get into that some of
them get into a little bit
of but you'll have the opportunity let's
say you had a uh
a client that had an investment
portfolio
uh that was uh 60 years old but he had a
30 year old daughter who was struggling
and brought her to you uh
and you could you know to help teach her
about budgeting in the process so we did
to do a lot of that kind of thing
in the crossfire like that the only
place in the banking world
where you're able to
where you're not forced with a quota a
boss breathing down your neck to sell
debt like you have experienced is
small town local banks community banks
aren't as aggressive
in the debt marketing and uh and credit
unions
that's why i endorse both both of those
and not the large
mega banks because the mega banks are
pretty well they're just pretty well
debt peddlers is what they do
they just if they figure if you're
breathing you need a bunch of their debt
and um i don't know which one you're
working at i didn't ask but
the the larger ones are much more
soulless
in their approach and um you know i've
got friends in the community banking
business
obviously i don't believe in borrowing
money i'll teach people borrow money but
they're much more responsible
with their interaction there's a moral
component for them with their
interaction with their customer
versus these mega banks they'll just
shovel as much down somebody's throat as
they can get in there
and and you know you're going to lose
your job if you don't sell a certain
amount of credit cards car loans and
home equity loans in your position
and i'll tell you that right the the
30 000 foot view of your question is you
can't work very long
in a job that violates a core value of
yours
whether that's treating people
disrespectfully whether that's like dave
said peddling food that you think
is not healthy selling debt at some
point you will begin to fracture from
the inside out yeah i mean let's just
completely change the metaphor let's
pretend that you
uh that alcoholism killed your father
and you don't believe in drinking and
drinking scares your death
you'd make a horrible bartender yeah
you know and that's that's what john's
talking about is
and you don't need to quit today we're
not suggesting you run in there with
your hair on fire and make some
political statement
we're not trying to create an act make
you into an activist okay
but the uh uh but you long term what is
good for you is to find something and
that's why
that's what that's the itch you've got
that's what you're scratching
is long term you need to find something
that is congruent with your belief
system and your values
you're not going to prosper otherwise
you're never going to be a really great
banker at that bank that's exactly right
and you're never going to be able to
sleep either yeah you know the boss
isn't going to be happy the customers
aren't going to be happy you're not
going to be happy
nobody's happy you're not selling enough
debt the customers are getting debt
they're not happy you're selling debt
you don't want to sell debt you're not
happy nobody's happy here yeah you know
and so
you know you're just you head on your
pillow dude and and so what i would do
is i develop a
you know like an 18-month runway or a
12-month runway that says all right i've
got to start
doing some of ken coleman's materials on
hunting for a career
thinking about a career i'm going to
investigate for instance the financial
advisory world
what's it take to get into that what
have i got to do what licensing have i
got to get what have i got to do to get
hired in that world
and begin to move in that direction but
um i i you know i
i would not ask a pizza place to not
sell pizza right
and i'm not going to ask a bank to not
sell debt i am going to ask all of you
to not buy it from them so that you're
not harmed
but i'm not going to expect an alligator
to quit biting it's what alligators do
and this is a common situation he says
he just graduated and started this job
that
he wanted to help people right we you
have a vision and this helps people with
money and bank's got money so i'll go
over there that's right man and but that
happens to
graduates all over the place right and
then they get in and gets you behind the
curtain see how the sausages made see
what we're actually doing here
and then they have a crisis of value
yeah right
crisis of conscience yeah it's very real
i appreciate you ryan you got a good
you're
a man of integrity and you weren't you
weren't being a drama queen about it you
weren't being crazy about it but you're
just going this just feels weird and i
don't think it's going to work and
you're right
it's not it's not going to work and
they're not going to change
right so how do you treat them with
dignity and then how do you hold your
head up highest when you go find
something else
you know you're going to be you're going
to suck at selling debt so they're going
to be happy when you leave